I believe we have a choice in this world
about how to tell sad stories on the one
hand you can sugarcoat it when nothing
is too messed up that can't be fixed
with a Peter Gabriel song
I like that version as much as the next
girl does it's just not the truth this
is the truth
make some friends sorry I've been I'm
Augustus waters I've been in remission
for about a year and a half maybe you'd
like to share some of your fears with
the group cheers oblivion what's your
name hazel what's your full name hazel
grace Lancaster why Serena tree is he
beautiful so what's your story who's
diagnosed mr. your real story I am quite
unexpected I reject that on the hand
you know Gus talks about you all the
time we're just friends I hope you
realize you're trying to keep your
distance from me and no way lessens my
affection for you cuz I'm a grenade one
day I'm gonna blow up and I'm gonna
blitar everything in my wake and I don't
want to hurt you you don't get to choose
if you get hurt in this world but you do
have a say in who hurts you I am in love
with you hazel grace and I know that
love is just a shout into the void and
that oblivion is inevitable and I am in
love with you all your efforts to keep
me from your gonna fail
we are a heartless
are you angry so angry you need to break
something
he gave me a forever within the numbered
days and I can't tell you how they cry
out for a little infinity to good life
hazel grace okay
ok
you